i'm not gonna give you a rundown of the
prey movie instead i'm gonna have a
little bit of a rant
this film is so good the fact that it's
not on cinemas is an absolute goddamn
crime
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so
i did a video a little earlier on the
sidetrack science channel telling you
that i got up nice and early this
morning to watch the prey predator movie
and i was disgusted to find out that
here in the uk it is a premiere and on
disney plus that when it says out on the
5th of august it doesn't actually mean
that it means it's out actually about
lunchtime on the 5th of august so i was
like i've got up for nothing
but
i then took myself off to work nice and
early so that i could finish nice and
early and i've come home and watched the
movie and i have to tell you
oh damn it's good
no spoilers in this video but i am going
to tell you that this film is probably
my favorite of all the predator sequels
anybody that says it's as good as
predator is talking out of their bum
hall i'm afraid predator is
one of a very small number of movies
it's actually perfect
it's actually
gotten nothing wrong with it at all it's
perfectly written perfectly acted
perfect special effects
it's it's not just perfect for its time
it's perfect full stop there's a handful
of movies that um can go onto that list
but this is a damn good movie
the only predator film that comes even
close to it is the 2010 predators which
actually i watched this morning when i
realized i couldn't watch
the predator
prey movie
so
without spoilers i'm going to tell you
again that the director dan trachtenberg
did a phenomenal job
he got the editing perfect
the tone is perfect it's respectful to
the comanche nation i love that they
actually have also filmed this in
comanche he said that's one of the
things that it was actually a benefit
about going straight to um hulu and
disney plus and that they would be able
to do this comanche version
i think that's a bit of a cop-out myself
because i think they could have done
that anyway but you know that's what he
said but he actually did a bloody good
job and this is probably the biggest
project he's done for me so far i mean
there's ten clover the lane and he's an
executive producer on the boys which
again you know if you're a regular
sidetracker as a show i absolutely adore
but yeah he's done a fantastic job with
this movie he got the editing as well is
also damn near perfect
um i would love to see a director's cut
to this film it's only an hour and 40
minutes i'd love to see like another 20
minutes added if there was anything
dumped on the editor's floor you know
the cutting room floor that they could
throw into this movie i'd love to see
that at some point in the future
but to get on to
the not having a cinema release
disney plus seemed to be jumping on the
bandwagon of netflix and amazon prime
who have for a long time now released
movies directly to their streaming
service the whole point is to get more
subscribers to the streamer service and
that's what they do
disney plus did this during the pandemic
i have no problem with the moon language
straight to disney plus in that case or
even the black widow was released on the
same day as cinema release
even though we know a few people weren't
very happy about that because but when a
big movie like prey comes out you would
hope it would get a cinema release
because after watching it this is a film
that deserved a cinema release
i have a pretty big tv i have quite a
nice sound system it's not as big as the
cinema and it's not as good as the
cinema sound system i actually genuinely
think i've missed out not getting to
experience this at the cinema
and i think as the customer if we don't
actually kick up a fuss about this the
cinema is going to die some people say
are but ease of access anybody can watch
it at home
but
that's true but anybody could watch it
at home in a few weeks when it's
released on disney plus light year is
already on disney plus it was in the
cinema about six weeks ago and they put
on disney plus straight away
it bombed which is one of the reasons
why it's on disney plus as quickly as it
is but
they could have done that with prey it
could have had a cinema release the
cinema release it deserves but still got
a quick disney plus release you could
get the best of both worlds but they
chose not to do that but why do they
chose to do it
you could argue that maybe they just
didn't have confidence in the movie but
they had enough confidence in it to give
it a decent budget i mean this film had
a good budget and it is shown on the
screen
so i don't really think that is it
it was always planned to be a straight
to hulu and then straight to disney plus
project it's touted as a hulu original
so that was the plan from day one and
again the interviews with the director
and executive producers show that so
this isn't something they've gone
you know what this isn't great let's
just put it on disney plus this isn't
you know the bat girl movie where
they've just decided to go and when
they've looked at it and going god this
is bloody awful we just need to get as
far away from this as possible
this was always the plan
but as i say they were always willing to
give her the budget so it wasn't a
confidence issue
even if it was an early stage as a
confident issue when they'd have seen
some of the early footage when they'd
have started getting the early cuts
you'd think executive producers or
people in charge of hulu would have gone
this is bloody good
this is the sequel to the original
predator movie that's all deserved
there is no way they didn't show this
movie to you know select audiences like
they do and their audience didn't go
crazy because this film is that good
so why did they do it they did it
because disney plus are trying to push
subscribers they want content for the
channel and they want these these kinds
of movies these specials that are only
available on disney plus
to appear on their network so that they
can push subscriber numbers further
now what do i think about that
i think if it continues along this trend
and if prime becomes through its
purchase of mgm really becomes uh one of
the big studios producing lots of movies
that go directly to amazon prime
netflix continue to make movies like the
gray man which is the most recent of
their movies that really knocks me that
isn't on um
we didn't get to see the cinema we
should have done it's a great movie
um
then it is going to mean the end of
cinema or at very least the end of
cinema as we know it
the problem is though that people
a lot of the time are inherently lazy if
a film is on at the cinema or it's on in
your living room a lot of the time
you're going to watch it in your living
room you're not going to make the effort
to go to the cinema
and what will be the net result of that
will lose them
so i hope this isn't a new trend i hope
this is a one-off but sadly we already
know it isn't
but i would love to know guys what you
think do you think the death of cinema
is really worth fighting against do we
want movies like this to appear at the
cinema because they deserve to if a film
is a good enough quality
should it be on the cinemas first even
if it is then very quickly on the
streaming services afterwards
i'd love to know what you think also if
you want to get into the comments and
tell me what you think of the movie
did you think all of the fear-mongering
about this being a woke mess was
deserved
do you actually think this like i do
that the people that are shouting this
would be a work mess are the same people
at the shelton that lord of the rings is
going to be a woke mess and that
actually maybe they should take their
lesson from this film which is
absolutely fantastic
and give the lord of the rings a chance
let's actually watch the series first
and then make a judgment on it
that's just my personal little rant on
that little subject i apologize
but if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification and if you enjoy the
content don't forget that you can hit
the join button and become a fully
fledged side tracker that really
supports the channel
as always guys please stay safe and uh
if you haven't watched predator prey
just yet
please go and get to the subscription
it's 7.99 it's cheap as chips watch the
movie cancel it immediately if i was you
if you don't want to have disney plus
it's worth it just for this film i
promise you thanks guys see you soon
[Music]
you